- Bon appetit! (laughs)
- What's gonna happen?
(playful music)
- In France we have, our French
fries are a little bigger,
a little thicker.
- I have had McDonald's
French fries in France,
and in Luxembourg, and in
the UK, but never in the US.
- And McDonalds adapts
the taste per country
for the country culture,
so each country is different tastes.
- So far my favorite McDonalds
food is by far in France,
because the meat is better,
the sauces are nicer,
so we're looking forward to
see how different it is here.
- They smell, they smell fresh and fatty,
we can smell the oil, definitely.
- Yeah.
- They're very light,
a bit mushy. (laughs)
That's point.
- Tastes like potatoes, tastes
like what it should taste.
- It tastes more plasticky, right?
Like it's been sitting there for awhile.
- I think the smell is
the best thing, honestly,
when you first get your Big Mac--
- Can you smell anything else than salt?
(laughs)
- These are not traditional French fries.
They are a bit more crispy,
a bit more salty, but,
they taste fine with me.
- It lacks salt.
- And it's not crispy enough.
- Doesn't taste as much,
not crispy enough, too oily.
- I can see it in my hands.
- I can see it, yeah,
it's still on my hand too.
- [Both] We prefer French fries from home.
- French fries in France are legit,
they're the real thing, you
know, it was a whole potato.
- I thought the fries are
fine, just, greasy and small,
like they've always been.
- Our French fries are a little
bigger, a little thicker,
but I like this one, they are like,
actually a little easier to eat.
- It didn't seem as fresh
here, didn't seem as--
- Not fresh, too oily.
The freshness is a very important thing,
to eat fast food you want it
to be very fresh, very tasty,
and if it's not, your disappointed.
- I like them, I can't
say I'd go and eat them
all the time but, they're
a little guilty pleasure
when I do.
(soft xylophone music)
(sign creaks)